de casablanca au quartier planoise à
besançon en juin dernier bouchra alioui
a ouvert la première boutique français
d'une grande marque marocaine de
prêt-à-porter depuis elle transmet son
amour de l'artisanat à ses nouveaux
clients
c'est moderne avec une touche marocaine
voilà il y aura toujours cette petite
touche en fait qu'il va rappeler le
travail marocain l'artisanat marocain
c'est les petits boutons là qui sont
travaillé minutieusement par des
artisans maroc à la main un projet qui a
séduit le jury du concours talents des
cités ce prix encourage la création
d'entreprises dans les quartiers
prioritaires
bouchra remporté la première place dans
la catégorie création un beau coup de
projecteur sur sa boutique et son
travail je ne croyais pas je sais très
ému et oui ce que j'ai ressenti c'est
que je me suis dit c'est ça va être pour
moi une une possibilité de pouvoir
justement montrer aussi aux futurs
entrepreneurs qui veut s'investir dans
des quartiers comme celui ci on peut y
arriver
à besançon la quasi-totalité des prix du
concours ont été attribués à des projets
implantés à planoise pour bouchra sa
boutique à bien plus qu'une vocation
commerciale
- l'objectif c'était au cul aussi
d'offrir quelque chose de nouveau au
planoise y en ait deux pas laisser
tomber de la noisy parce que planoise
aujourd'hui c'est un quartier on va dire
la difficulté
le projet sera présenté en finale
départementale en septembre prochain